now empires back empire is back 11
million strong premier week number one
show
why is 50 steel trying to diss I don't
know flu what's his problem but I don't
think he's gonna mess with the two
sisters anymore between myself and
cookie I think that that's a battle that
he now knows he won't win when it comes
to the Empire family we are strong and
very strong United so you guys beat up
on social media this year that's what
happens when you mess with the Lions
right those claws come out and you might
not be able to you might walk over but
you don't limp back so I think that
that's kind of what happened but you
know listen just like taraji who plays
my sister on empire says there's enough
room for all of us to have a wonderful
time this is such a blessing especially
for African Americans to have so many so
many shows to choose from the fact that
you just have so many shows that are
thriving and delivering ratings is
something that we should celebrate and
not be fighting over and that was the
main main main voice and main thing main
thing that taraji and myself wanted to
stress was that let's celebrate and
stick together and lick one another up
no no none of that other bad behavior